by the way so you when you were coming
up
and you're saying 21 you kind of knew
because then you know i'm trying to act
like i don't want to afford this kind of
weird and then you're like i'm going to
go give this a shot i was working i was
a banker i was at lehman brothers
21 33 right out of college i was a
history major i [ __ ] my way into the
accounts receivable payables department
and i just dude i was there for 16
months and i was like i i i just don't
care about mortgage-backed securities i
was taking a class on that i kept i got
good rem sleep in that class good guys
i just wasn't my thing bro if you cared
a little bit more about it you could
have prevented a 2008 meltdown maybe
mortgage
guys bring them in if i looked at the
tranches
were you their late 80s early 90s when i
was there in uh yeah i was there i
graduated 89 i was there 89 90 91 wow
yeah yeah what a time to be like that
was right it wasn't an intent i
attempted uh goldman sachs for almost
two years and uh this is where where
were you i was in new york city in new
york yeah so i i just i mean i worked a
couple blocks away from the world trade
center so so so you know uh goldman
sachs was where i saw back then dude
that the quality of people they'd get
you come in i would see the resumes
you'd come in you'd be like a delta
force guy set yourself through harvard
and you had you could play the cello you
know and you spoke 20 languages and
they'd be like you know what nah wow it
was unbelievable the quality how did you
get in i was a i was an actor
i was an actor writing bad plays doing
stand-up doing whatever i could was it
your personality that sold it or no like
was it a res because it's not the resume
right it's the personality did they meet
you they're like we like this guy yeah i
can fi i
just so you know that's exactly how i
got my job at morgan stanley i was just
going to say that
let me tell you you know
you you're talking of uh vince vaughn
and and vince asks you questions good
friend of mine good friend
so you're talking about you say so tell
me what are the three that he asked you
to question exactly what are the three
things you say
well i was interviewing a lot of models
women about what they're looking for in
a man and comes along vince vaughn i'm
like hey vince you want to do an
interview yeah valuetainment ppd oh yeah
i know that what's up what's up so i say
well you know you're the famous wedding
crasher what advice do you have for men
well you know here's what i think and he
goes and and nobody does this and this
kind of goes to your point of being
curious and inquisitive he goes i don't
know but i see you asking all the women
what are your thoughts
i go thanks vince vaughn you know well
vince and vince's i know him a little
bit too and and vince is it's also
helpful that you're six five and
handsome yeah extremely dangerous yeah
he's a good looking guy but he's also a
guy who never was a womanizer he never
was he never he was out to hang with his
boys
he was driving a cutlass
a cutlass at the height of his
you know powers that guys wingers he was
never a womanizer no i i mean i know
from what i know
you know um he was never that guy who
was out i mean he could he could find
he'd find a girl in his
in his glove compartment they were
hiding everything yeah friends have done
movies with him and they're like dude
it's crazy but he never was uh he wasn't
that guy he was just he was more about
hanging with his boys
so he asked him a question he said so uh
he says hey vince you'd be surprised
what all the girls are saying is the
most biggest turn on for them he says
what's that humor he says yep getting
them to laugh he said we can get him so
with humor you can get into so many
crazy it's insane because
vinnie's like how do you think i get
laid out here yeah by the way i'm not
rich i'm not in movies but i just it's
just something where we're and it's
weird like i mean i've seen the hottest
hottest girls that are just like what's
some dude he's like he makes me laugh
well is that it think about think about
the times the friendships you have and
the the things you hold on to the guys
you call you've known for 20 years what
is the connective tissue it's the times
you were laughing man
it's the times you were just you know
it's like that george carlin thing too
it's like there there are times you feel
the most alive and you almost forget
you're human one is inspiration
right it's like george carlin said don't
worry about the number of breaths you
take how many breaths how many how many
breaths are taken away how often are you
it's so true because that would mean
that's sort of that moment of
inspiration you hear an amazing piece of
music you see an amazing movie you you
you uh are are having this moment with
your friends where you would rather be
nowhere else or it's a moment with a
woman where you like i i love this
whatever those moments are you forget
you're human so it's like laughter
laughter is intimacy man laughter if i'm
not laughing or learning get me out of
there bro like i'll see you later i got
i got kids you know yeah dude i'm we're
so alive there i mean it's it's you
when you you ever you ever been in a
you're shooting the [ __ ] with friends
you're at the house you're smoking
cigars you're at a bar wherever you are
and then all of a sudden you're looking
at your watch you're like
it's 2 30 in the morning exactly what
the hell just happened
great conversations great laughter it's
an unbelievable high and add food at
great that's it that's mandatory i'm
sorry forgive me for forgetting that
because without the food
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]